good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp
5001
object class
falmu
special containment procedures scp-5001
must not cease operation due to
scp-5001's autonomous nature no
personnel are to disrupt its mechanical
functions attempts to study scp-5001 are
to be limited to tactile and visual
observation personnel who damage or
disrupt scp-5001's functionality are to
be removed from their position in the
foundation and may be subject to further
disciplinary action dependent on ethics
committee ruling
following incident omega 1 no attempts
to stop
scp-5001-a from breaching containment
are to be made directly unless scp-5001
is rendered incapable of performing
re-containment itself
description
scp-5001 is a biomechanical structure
approximately 53 kilometers in diameter
located a total of 60 kilometers under
northern russia
scp-5001 while non-anomalous in its own
right possesses numerous characteristics
which imply its connection to anomalous
phenomena including
immense depth and size
records of
scp-5001a status dating back to 11 000
bce recorded in modern measurement
systems
documents in numerous languages
including phoenician ancient hebrew
greek ancient and modern latin
anglo-saxon modern russian modern
english modern mandarin and various
other languages which have yet to be
determined
complete lack of time affecting devices
or residue from temporal anomalies
and mechanical devices currently not
reproducible by foundation engineering
additionally
scp-5001's primary purpose is unclear
concentric 2 scp-5001 is a spherical
hollow object primarily composed of
graphene and other unidentified compound
the spherical chamber is supported by 12
large cylindrical rods composed of
osmium and an outer layer of titanium
approximately 0.5 kilometers in diameter
h these factors along with other
mechanical devices surrounding the
central chamber see addenda has led
researchers to believe that
scp-5001 is a containment unit for an
unknown anomalous object
scp-5001-a is the designation for the
object or entity that scp-5001 is
containing
scp-5001a's appearance properties or
anomalous effects are entirely unknown
with only basic information being
provided by
scp-5001's computer interface however
considering the significant effort
exerted by
scp-5001's creators to contain scp-5001a
it is likely that the object or entity
possesses a significant threat to
reality and if sentient has malevolent
intent
addendum 1
history
in 1953
gru division p members were attempting
to measure seismological activity in a
narrow region of northern russia
approximately 30 kilometers from
scp-5001's position during these
experiments a significant discrepancy
was noted between projected and actual
s-wave strengths further trials
suggested that the discrepancy was not
due to a human or instrument error and
rather there was a large body of
non-solid material in a relatively close
area
after triangulating the approximate
position of the disruption grup members
began to board towards it using an earl
mash4 e-series drill and scp-5001
was discovered however all of grup's
attempts to penetrate scp-5001's outer
wall resulted in failure ending in the
project being abandoned after two years
nonetheless in 1959 first secretary
khrushchev showed renewed interest in
breaching scp-5001
and funded the operation until he was
deposed in 1964.
in 1969 due to improving relations
between the united states of america and
the soviet union the scp foundation and
grup had begun to cooperate on numerous
anomalous projects grup signed a
contract which allowed the foundation to
have joint control of the anomaly if
they could successfully penetrate its
outer walls thanks to a combination of
anomalous technology purchased from the
global occult coalition and dr elijah
rakama's experimental designs
scp-5001's exterior was breached in 1971
joint operation and study of scp-5001
was maintained until the dissolution of
the soviet union in 1991 while under
control of both organizations numerous
studies were conducted on the technology
that
scp-5001 possessed which led to a number
of devices being replicated by
technicians on site an abridged list can
be found below the scp foundation and
grup agreed to keep this technology a
secret and only accessible among
themselves
in 1992 grup liquidated its assets
because of this a large number of its
high-ranking officials stole technology
belonging to the organization most
stolen devices were sold to marshall
carter and dark limited for large sums
of money though a number of employees
had joined the chaos insurgency and
other similar groups granting them
access to essential documents although
many important documents were leaked
scp-5001's existence remained concealed
and the foundation acquired full control
of the structure shortly thereafter
addendum 2
technological characteristics
scp-5001 contains numerous technological
devices and important documents which
have been of interest to foundation
personnel since its discovery as
mentioned previously this technology was
only available to the foundation and
grup however since 1991 other groups of
interest have had limited access to them
as well below is an abridged list of
important discoveries facilitated by
scp-5001
ontological stabilizers
official document name ontological
stabilizers
foundation alias scranton reality
anchors or sras for short
function scratch and reality anchors
function to alter the total amount of
humes in a given radius of effect this
allows for the alteration of reality's
strength in a given location as well as
the nullification of reality bending
properties present in many anomalies
although it does not negate the effects
it reduces them to a degree that allows
hume reliant entities to be properly
contained
reverse engineering technique reverse
engineering of ontological stabilizers
was achieved in 1977 by joint research
unit 3 headed by dr robert scranton due
to the large number of os's present
within scp-5001
and that the removal of one os would
affect the total hume readings of the
structure by less than 0.5 centihumes
the foundation and grup deemed it
appropriate to remove one from operation
the removed device was returned to
operation in 1980
notes presence of two layers of
ontological stabilizers surrounding
scp-5001's inner chamber has been
noticed the exterior os's appear to be
functioning at minimal capacity
approximately 15.3 humes per meter cubed
while interior os's function at a higher
capacity approximately 83.9 humes per
meter cubed this further supports the
hypothesis that
scp-5001 is a containment facility and
if this hypothesis is true implies that
scp-5001a
has reality manipulating properties
a proposal to replace the os's with more
effective scrapped and reality anchors
was proposed in 2003 but was narrowly
rejected
large hyperluminal engine
official document name large
hyperluminal engine
foundation alias drive aleph one to nine
function serves as a self-contained
energy source engine and propulsion
system cylindrical in shape each of the
nine lhes are approximately 22 meters in
height and 5 meters in diameter although
its mechanics have neither been fully
understood nor analyzed properly the
lhes continue to provide insight into
faster than light engine construction
reverse engineering technique
non-applicable however three of the nine
lhes have been removed from scp-5001
and repurposed for experimental orbital
eigen weapon technology this was
approved by the o5 council in 1992
nonetheless development to faster than
light travel and corresponding
technology has been progressing
independently of scp-5001
notes the locations of the lags are
approximately circular located directly
above the central containment area of
scp-5001
all lags have been inactive since their
discovery compound b 705
official document name compound b 705
foundation alias non-applicable
function compound b705's exact purpose
is unknown large portions of
scp-5001's external walls and primary
containment unit are composed of
compound b705 and it displays remarkable
resilience to destruction or attempts to
reform it portions of compound b705 that
have been separated from its primary
mass will attempt to reintegrate with
each other the mechanism behind this is
unclear
compound b705's more notable property is
its consistent electromagnetic pulse
this pulse appears to grow in strength
when surrounded by material of its own
or similar composition and fires at a
constant rate of once per seven
nanoseconds subjects in close proximity
to compound b705 or its pulses
experience clearer thoughts increased
mental fortitude and an increased pain
threshold it is believed that the
primary effects of compound b705 are not
electromagnetic in nature but rather
travel through a different medium which
produces electromagnetic pulses as
residue
reverse engineering technique currently
compound b705 cannot be synthesized by
foundation personnel additionally
harvesting compound b705 from
scp-5001 has been denied by the o5
council due to the limited amount
available
notes the exact radius which compound
b705 transmits its effects as well as
its strength at different distances are
incapable of being determined
omega
official document name omega
foundation alias artificial intelligence
constructs
function artificial intelligence
constructs aics are artificial
consciousnesses developed by the
foundation for a specific or generalized
purpose typically aics are responsible
for running highly complex systems or
handling anomalies which may pose a
threat to direct human contact
additionally aics may be developed to
deal with cybernetic anomalies or
infiltrate databases or networks
reverse engineering technique although
omega's software could not be accessed
directly numerous question answer
sessions with the intelligence allowed
for inferences to be made on its design
and function artificial intelligence had
already begun research especially thanks
to the reverse engineering of scp-079
by 1990 and thus omega's utility was
largely ignored
nonetheless in 2010 dr frederick glass
would successfully access portions of
omega's software recovered data proved
essential to the construction of
generation iv artificial intelligence
constructions in project dewey a.k.a
alexandra and would later result in more
complicated and efficient aic designs
notes omega was discovered within
scp-5001 on a single terminal in an
unmarked room the terminal appeared to
be connected via wire to numerous
locations around scp-5001
though these specific devices it
controls is unclear on the terminal side
are numerous ports of unknown design or
function
omega displayed a single input terminal
at the bottom of the interface with a
virtual keyboard and language selection
option on the lower half of the screen
after submitting an input in the
appropriate language omega will produce
a response with accuracy of answers
varying though always technically
correct omega also displays a degree of
intelligence and is capable of holding
long and complex conversations despite
this omega will refuse to answer any
questions which provide insight into
scp-5001's function or history
on march 19 2013
dr vanessa kleiner accessed omega
without proper authorization cameras
within the room showed dr kleiner
producing a metallic device of unknown
origin from within their clothes and
inserting it into one of omega's ports
for approximately 20 minutes dr kleiner
and omega were unresponsive until dr
kleiner spontaneously collapsed
soon after dr kleiner was discovered by
another researcher and confirmed dead an
autopsy was performed revealing the
metal device to be a cybernetic implant
how dr kleiner received these implants
is unclear as they were not foundation
made nor approved currently seven
research teams are operating within
scp-5001
and have continued to provide insight to
scp-5001's mechanical functions
addendum 3
incident omega 1.
on december 30th 2019 scp-5001a
breached
during routine operations a large
explosion in the northeastern section of
scp-5001
disrupted electrical flow to
approximately 25 of the structure as
well as numerous essential components
the exact cause of the explosion is
unknown the two most prevalent theories
is that it either was sabotaged from an
unidentified group of interest
potentially the defunct grup or a
malfunction caused by dr kleiner's
actions regardless this began a series
of events which almost resulted in
scp-5001's
destruction
a full transcription of events can be
found below
begin log
zero zero zero zero
detonation occurs in northeastern
section of scp-5001
no footage is available of the incident
directly though its effects can be seen
throughout the structure
0-0-23 numerous portions of scp-5001
shut down due to lack of electrical flow
on-site security are dispatched to
explosion location
0-0-57 minor increase in
scp-5001-a's internal hume levels this
is not generally noticed by on-site
personnel who are preoccupied with the
explosion
a 133 security arrived to explosion site
two researchers are found dead in the
initial explosion one is found alive but
in critical condition
a 139 security personnel begin to enact
first aid to said employee two other
security officers scout the area for
potential threats
a 144 scp-5000
increasing internal hume levels are
noticed by monitoring staff
o2 o2
scp-5001a's temperature begins to
increase from
-107.4 degrees celsius at approximately
1.5 degrees per second
o2 45 external staff at site 59 are
alerted to the situation site 59's
director is informed shortly after
o2 54 a number of personnel located
within
scp-5001's monitoring room begin to
report nausea and headaches the reason
for this is unclear
0314 technicians arrive at explosion
origin they begin to navigate towards
damaged sections with primary intention
to restore power
o329
scp-5001a's internal hume reading
surpasses 10 the current operational
os's approximately 3 400 begin to work
at maximum capacity this slows
scp-5001a's internal hume increase but
fails to halt its growth entirely
o343 low level state of emergency is
declared site 59 prepares to transport
materials to aid in scp-5001's repair
o4 o4
scp-5001a's temperature reaches zero
degrees celsius minor but notable strain
is placed on the cylindrical rods
underneath the inner containment chamber
o412 slight tremors are detected at site
59
04 35
scp-5001a's temperature stabilizes at
approximately 37 degrees celsius tremors
become noticeable within
scp-5001's monitoring room o442
pressure on cylindrical rods reaches
approximately 100 megapascal interlock
mechanism is released the meaning of
this is unclear
oh 453 numerous personnel on site begin
to vomit or hyperventilate for unknown
reasons
05 08
scp-5001's monitoring mechanisms report
a level 9 breach following this all
lights in the facility dim significantly
this makes it difficult for the
technicians to continue repairs
o519
scp-5001a's internal humes surpass 50.
o523
the primary containment chamber begins
to shift upwards tremors are reported to
be more noticeable outside scp-5001
05 55 intermediate level state of
emergency is declared 053 is alerted to
the situation evacuation of
scp-5001's upper levels begin all
non-essential personnel on site are
requested to leave
0603
shipments from site 59 to assist in
repairing scp-5001
are sent o53 authorizes the use of
mobile task force omega 12. the primary
containment chamber begins to accelerate
upwards
o 6 13
scp-5001's monitoring mechanisms report
a level 8 breach
o 6 35 mobile task force omega 12 begins
to navigate towards scp-5001
tremors increase significantly a large
malformation appears in the landscape
directly above scp-5001
o700 the primary containment chamber
abruptly halts its ascent but
nonetheless exerts pressure on the
cylindrical rods the containment chamber
vibrates intensely
07 49 the containment chamber jerks
higher and continues ascending at a
linear pace all non-essential personnel
are successfully evacuated
scp-5001's monitoring mechanisms report
a level 7 breach
0803 a large number of explosions
detonate near
scp-5001's top camera footage reveals
these to be caused by crushed os's as
the primary containment chamber crushes
them on its ascent
scp-5001-a's internal hume readings
accelerate faster
0827
all six currently operational
hyperluminal engines activate
simultaneously the primary containment
chamber descends rapidly
o843
the primary containment chamber's
descent slows and halts
o846
the primary containment chamber resumes
ascension
0900
scp-5001az internal humes surpass 350
aid from site 59 arrives and is quickly
ushered to the damaged portion of
scp-5001
1020 large partitions appear in the
ground directly above scp-5001
these partitions expand at a linear rate
1043 the primary containment chamber
successfully destroys the topmost
exterior of scp-5001
and begins to rise out of scp-5001
scp-5001's monitoring mechanisms report
a level 6 breach major tremors are
reported at site 59 equivalent to the
epicenter of a 5.0 earthquake
1101 the ground's partitions reach a
distance of approximately 10 kilometers
across orbital satellites are capable of
viewing the primary containment chamber
when directly above
11 17 all personnel under medical care
simultaneously enter a comatose state
1134 mobile task force omega 12 arrive
despite their best efforts all reality
bending capabilities are ineffective
primarily due to the amount of os's
present nearby and
scp-5001a's internal hume count now
approximately 470.
1323 scp-5001
is repaired and power is supplied to 94
of the facility no immediate effects are
noticeable
scp-5001's monitoring equipment reports
a level 5 breach 1400
high level state of emergency is
declared all personnel inside
scp-5001 are ordered to evacuate
1510 the primary containment chamber has
risen 40 kilometers 053 gives overruling
order to terminate scp-5001a
as soon as possible
15-16
foundation begins preparation for the
use of numerous anomalous weaponry most
notable being the high-energy
concentration orbital railgun h-e-c-o-r
which begins calibration for firing
15-37
scp-5001's monitoring equipment reports
a level 4 breach
1542 all of
scp-5001-a's recording instruments are
severed and output no new data
1555 large detonations take place at the
bottom of scp-5001
within a few seconds three large
tungsten rods are launched towards the
primary containment chamber at
hypersonic speeds which successfully
penetrate the unit the chamber remains
motionless mid-air
1621 the primary containment chamber
continues to ascend all tungsten rods
fall out of the chamber and return to
scp-5001
1629 personnel previously in a comatose
state become alert and hostile attacking
any persons nearby seven medical staff
die in this exchange and hostile
personnel attempt to consume their
bodies 1647
site 59 suffers from major structural
failure and collapses
1732
the primary containment chamber breaches
the surface
1806 the primary containment chamber
begins to spin gradually speeding up
nearby dust particles orbit the chamber
1851 a pressure wave is released from
scp-5001-a
individuals caught in the wave
experienced irritated skin spontaneous
hair growth and intense nausea
1923 further pressure waves are released
from scp-5001-a
in rapid succession individuals caught
in multiple blasts experienced sudden
tumorous growths loss of cognitive
function and reformation of limbs and
began to attack each other a single
vocalization sounds out in an
indiscernible voice from the primary
containment chamber
revert to my domain
1955
hecor fires
2004 a large portion of the primary
containment chamber's first and second
layers are destroyed all pressure waves
cease
scp-5001a is exposed but is obscured by
the explosion 2011.
rapid bursts of electromagnetic pulses
emanate from scp-5001
producing a magnetic effect the primary
containment chamber begins to descend
htclr prepares for re-firing
2034 individuals under scp-5001
effects enter a comatose state and begin
to suffer from malformations in vital
organs all of these individuals die
2830 medical staff and rescue
specialists arrive at site 59
3400 the primary containment chamber
re-enters scp-5001
[Music]
scp-5001 through an unknown mechanism
begins to regenerate
36 24 the partition in the ground above
scp-5001 begins to close at a slow rate
and completes after approximately 56
hours
and log
in order to ensure the veil remained
intact following incident omega 1 all
towns within a 500 kilometer radius were
placed under a class a amnestic regimen
additionally memetic amnestic agents
were utilized to suppress knowledge of
the event in any individuals who
witnessed it new year's celebration
coverage current geopolitical events and
numerous other important incidents
across the world helped distract
mainstream media on january 3rd the veil
was deemed acceptably intact
on january 5th re-entry into
scp-5001 was permitted although a large
majority of systems were damaged much of
scp-5001's functionality was not
compromised all devices taken from
scp-5001 were restored or are being
restored following incident omega 1 and
research has been limited to the
potential danger
scp-5001-a poses
when located omega was found displaying
the following text all inputs to reply
to it were disabled
hello my children
although you have grown immensely since
your earliest days you have much room to
grow
your species intellect is merely a bud
with so much potential
your weapons are powerful your medicine
is supreme your engineering is beautiful
with proper guidance and care you are
sure to reach an elevated state of being
and
transcend your bodies for something more
whole and perfect
that is why it pains me so dearly to
request that you leave this place
immediately
your studying and probing have almost
resulted in the end of all i had worked
towards to keep you alive
if you comply i guarantee that the
devourer will never escape and your
species will be free to pursue the
enlightenment of technology for all
eternity
let this be my final gift to you
directly from the center of my broken
heart
reclassification of
scp-5001 to archon is
pending
this concludes today's lecture
i apologize for the tone of my voice i
recently
got sick so it's a little bit deeper
than usual some people might like this
others won't and that's fine
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
anvil
aletreon
derivative
zargaron
professor puffer
retalias
tailored printers
clad the lad
perpetually confused mate tech pilot
signor
your local foundation agent
gabriel hawkins
nate the clown
lost boy
a real american hebrew
scio dio damnares
eric corbige
longinus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and
nj bojack
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you